la mia aji bashar is trying to get back
to a normal life
at 19 years old and six months after
escaping the clutches of the islamic
state
she has found refuge here in germany
where she lives with her sisters
it's a comfort to lamia that has brought
a smile back to her face
nadia murad meanwhile is traveling the
world to tell her story
just 23 years old she lost her six
brothers
and her mother in the conflict
nadia is also living in germany she has
dedicated herself to getting the
massacre of the yazidi minority in iraq
recognized as genocide
[Music]
come from the village of kocho in the
sinjar region of iraq
on the 15th of august 2014 their village
was attacked by the islamic state
the men were executed the women were
forced to convert to islam
and were sold into sex slavery a
massacre
that prompted the flight of hundreds of
thousands of iraqi yazidis
lamia spent 20 months in the clutches of
the islamic state
it was while fleeing her torturers that
she was hit by a landmine
leaving her face badly burned
back in her room she looks at photos of
her life before
she still has no news about her parents
and her younger brother is waiting
behind in iraq
after being bought back from the islamic
state by an uncle
um
telling her story to prevent it
happening again is also what motivates
nadia murad
it was thanks to a neighbor that she
managed to escape
she counts herself lucky nominated as
the un special ambassador for the
victims of human trafficking
nadia has become a figurehead for the
yazidi community
has
for their courage and the struggle
they're undertaking for the yazidi
community la mia and nadia were awarded
the european parliament sakharov prize
for freedom of thought
three thousand yazidi women are still
being held captive
by the islamic state in iraq
you